no doubt 99% of people are going to make
a Rock'em Sock'em robots reference in
the intro to their video so I'm going to
give you a little fun-filled fact did
you know that the term for someone who
has an extreme love for movies is called
a cinephile I'm Jeremy and I'm a
cinephile sounds creepy but it's awesome
and that was random but important
Real Steel where I saw the trailer for
Real Steel I thought what everyone
thought I made jokes like everyone made
jokes I was like the Rock'em Sock'em
robots movie not above making references
now and I was like this movie's gonna
suck I have no hope for it it's gonna be
then I started here in early
reviews and people were like this
movie's actually surprisingly good like
people who are really credible too I
mean they have a head on the shoulders
they know what they're talking about and
they were like it's good and how was
Real Steel it was actually really good
holy crap I'm getting emotional in a
movie about Robo boxing I tweeted that
immediately you notice the tones not
what you think it was going to be only a
couple parts in this movie look
futuristic and that's anything and
everything that has to do with robot
boxing including the stadiums and
whatnot and the cell phones other than
that if there were featuring things that
were really subtle I like that I hate it
when things to shove sci-fi down your
throat so real still starts out with
Hugh Jackman and he's he's a bit of a
scumbag actually he's sleazy he's shady
he's desperate for money he needs to put
a robot into a fight he needs to get a
big fight going he needs money because
he owes a bunch of people money I know
someone like that and they're annoying
don't ever loan people like that money
games or DVDs because you will never get
them back ever and you really see that
his deadbeat persona is just nailed
right in when he has to have his kid
with him now and he's like alright what
paper do I need to sign to release my
custody of the kid I don't want the kid
so right there you're like he's a bit of
a dick I don't see them bonding but like
I said the movie surprised me and I like
the kid at first I was like that kids
way too smart he's way too much of a
smartass just like that girl from True
Grit but a boy in the future he finds
this robot that's just made for sparring
you know it's pretty much a tank and an
MMO can take hits it can't really dish
him out and he's small - he's like the
little Mack of robots and after that the
robot wins a fight he surprises everyone
and then the movie unfolds exactly how
you think it would unfold I put it to
you this way a deadbeat dad and his son
they don't know each other at all but
now they have to stay together for the
summer the dad needs money and then they
find this robot that wins a fight how do
you think the movie's going to unfold it
unfolds exactly like that that's my one
gripe about the movie the movies really
predictable but I'm not really gonna
knock it stick with the formula it works
but it was really cool of me seeing Hugh
Jackman and his kid actually bond and
seeing the fights and the montages yeah
it has a montage and it's awesome like
he's training the robot as to how to
fight you know the robots copying his
movement so it's all like I was looking
for reason to do that
there's no relevance and I'm gonna level
with you the last stretch of fights I
get to a point where it's like alright
you have to now win these fights you
know the end of the movie the climax of
it all of those fights dude it's
David and Goliath scenario and the last
one he has to fight is like it's like
the Sandman of robots he's big he's
black he means business any piece of
living out a little Mac how can I
not talk about punch-out in this review
and that dude's in this movie you know
the guy who plays a dick in everything I
always say that in every movie he's in
he's in this movie and guess what he
plays a dick in real steel the
soundtrack in the movie had that Firefly
tone going on you know that dared own a
damn demon I like that stuff too I don't
know why I just like the twang
yeah the twang so I mean the acting was
good I liked the characters I liked
seeing the characters bond the fights
were exciting in the end I walked out of
this movie going I would buy this movie
on blu-ray and I'd love to see it again
surprise man is like Rocky meets daddy
issues meets robots as a winning
combination if I've ever known one so
real still have you seen it are you
gonna see it I want to know what you
guys think about it so comment below let
me know and as always you feel like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more